THERE, SO I HOPE YOU WILL STICK
AROUND FOR US IF YOU DON’T MIND.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BE HAPPY TO.
>> I THINK WE HAVE SENATOR TED
CRUZ STANDING BY.
SENATOR, ARE YOU THERE?
SENATOR, ARE YOU WITH US?
>> I AM.
>> THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I’M GOING TO ASK YOU THE
QUESTION THAT I’VE ASKED, YOU’RE
WATCHING THESE PICTURES, YOU
FOLLOWED THIS FOR THE PAST THREE
DAYS, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
AND WHERE DO YOU THINK IT’S
GOING?
>> LISTEN, IT’S HORRIFIC AND IT
STARTS WITH A HORRIFIC ACT OF
POLICE BRUTALITY.
ANY TIME YOU HAVE A POLICE
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING, THE
MEDIA OFTEN GOES INTO A FRENZY
AND THERE’S AN IMMEDIATE
DEMONIZATION AND ATTACK OF THE
POLICE OFFICERS.
I THINK THAT’S WRONG AND
PREMATURE.
THAT BEING SAID, IN THIS
INSTANCE WE HAVE A VIDEO OF THE
INCIDENT AND WE CAN SEE WITH
MISTER FLOYD, THE OFFICER WITH
HIS KNEE ON HIS NECK FOR EIGHT
MINUTES, MISTER FLOYD HAS IS
HANDCUFFED, HE IS CLEARLY
INCAPACITATED HE IS BEGGING FOR
HIS LIFE AND WHAT WE SAW WAS
WRONG.
THERE IS NO LEGITIMATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSE FOR WHAT WAS
ALL RIGHT THERE.
>> I’M SORRY, IT LET ME STOP
RIGHT THERE AND ASK A QUESTION,
I AGREE WITH YOU I FOUND THE
VIDEO VERY UPSETTING.
THERE IS A LOT OF ABUSE OF POWER
BY A LOT OF PEOPLE IN CHARGE, DO
YOU BELIEVE SINCE LET’S JUST
DEAL WITH FACTS HERE, DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THE MAN IN CUSTODY
DIED OF SUFFOCATION BECAUSE THE
POLICE OFFICER WAS SITTING ON
HIM?
>> I DON’T KNOW, WE WILL HAVE TO
SEE WITH THE MEDICAL EVIDENCE
SHOWS.
>> ISN’T THAT THE QUESTION?
EITHER THE COP KILLED HIM OR HE
DIDN’T.
>> THE QUESTION IS WAS THAT
ABUSE OF POLICE BRUTALITY.
>> THE GUY HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
MURDER SO ISN’T THE QUESTION WAS
DID HE KILL HIM.
>> THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS THE CIVIL RIGHTS
INVESTIGATION WHICH WAS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO, I APPLAUDED
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
DOING THAT.
NUMBER TWO, THE PROSECUTOR CHOSE
TODAY TO BRING HOMICIDE CHARGES.
TO PROVE THAT THEY WILL HAVE TO
PROVE THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT
.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THE MEDICAL
EXAMINER WILL DETERMINE ON THAT
SO WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS
HOMICIDE WILL DEPEND ON THE
EVIDENCE,  BUT IT WAS CLEARLY
POLICE BRUTALITY AND IT WAS NOT
CONDUCT WE EXPECT OF ANY
OFFICERS.
>> I TOTALLY AGREE WITH THAT.
I THINK IT WAS AWFUL, I’VE
COVERED THIS KIND OF THING
BEFORE AND I HATE IT, HOWEVER
THE COUNTRY IS CONVULSING THE
BASIS OF THE IDEA THAT THE COP
KILLED THIS MAN WHO WAS
RESTRAINED, HE WAS IN HANDCUFFS.
I THINK IT’S A MEANINGFUL
QUESTION, IT’S NOT SOMETHING WE
CAN GLIDE OVER AND SAY WHAT
DOESN’T MATTER WHY WOULDN’T
MATTER?
>> SAYING THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
WILL DEPEND ON WHAT THE WEATHER
THEY CASE BE IT’S NOT GLIDING
OVER A.
>> IT’S NOT AND I AGREE WITH YOU
100 PERCENT.
>> ONE OF THE REASON SADLY THAT
WE ARE SEEING THIS VIOLENCE AND
THIS RIOTING IS THAT YOU HAVE
LOTS OF DEMIGODS THAT WANT TO
USE THIS INCIDENT OF CLEAR ABUSE
BY ONE POLICE OFFICER AND THEY
WANT TO USE IT TOO PAY EVERY
POLICE OFFICER IS CORRUPT AND
RACIST.
MOST POLICE OFFICERS HEROICALLY
RISK THEIR LIVES TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITIES THEY ARE IN OFTEN
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND FOR
EVERYONE THAT IS STIRRING UP
RACIAL DIVISION AND ENGAGING IN
VIOLENCE AND LOOTING, THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
VIOLENCE AND CRIMINAL CONDUCT IS
UNACCEPTABLE WHETHER IT IS
COMMITTED BY A MOB ENRAGED OR
WHETHER IT’S COMMITTED BY A
POLICE OFFICER WHO IS BREAKING
THE LAW.
THE LAW SHOULD APPLY FAIRLY TO
EVERYONE PAIRED.
>> WHY IS THAT DIFFICULT FOR SO
MANY REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON
TO SAY.
I SAW THE TAPE, THE GUY SHOULD
BE PUNISHED FOR DOING IT, YOU’RE
NOT ALLOWED TO BURN OUR CITIES
DOWN.
I AM HEARING SILENCE FROM THE
THAT I HAVE VOTED FOR.
WHY DOESN’T SOMEBODY STICK UP
FOR THE REST OF US, YOU’RE NOT
ALLOWED TO BURN CARS.
YOU’RE SAYING IT?
>> I CAN’T SPEAK FOR OTHERS,
BUT IT’S AN OBVIOUS REACTION,
PROTECT PEOPLE’S LIVES AND
RIGHTS, AND I WILL POINT OUT
THAT THERE IS SOME IRONY THAT IN
MINNEAPOLIS, THE LOCAL OFFICIALS
, THE STATE OFFICIALS,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, THE
SENATORS, THEY’RE ALL DEMOCRATS
AND YOU GET A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE PLAYING THIS FOR PARTISAN
ADVANTAGE YET ONE OF THE
UNFORTUNATE THINGS ABOUT A LOT
OF ELECTED DEMOCRATS AND WE SEE
THIS DURING THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC IS THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO BE AUTHORITARIAN,
THEY ARE WILLING TO GET PEOPLE
TO ARREST FOR OR WOMEN PADDLE
BOARDING, AND IF YOU BELIEVE IN
LIBERTY COMMIT THEN YOU WANT TO
SEE POLICE OFFICERS KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE, AND NOT ABUSING
PEOPLE’S RIGHTS OR LIBERTIES.
>> I COULDN’T AGREE MORE.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF THIS
RECENTLY.
I WANT TO ASK YOU A QUESTION AND
THEY DON’T KNOW IF IT’S
ANSWERABLE.
YOU WATCHED IT CLOSELY FOR A
LONG TIME, WHERE DO YOU THINK
THIS IS GOING?
>> I THINK WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD
DEMAGOGUES AND WE HAVE SEEN YOU
AND I ARE BOTH OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER RODNEY KING AND HIS
PLEA CAN’T WE JUST GET ALONG?
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT WE
CAN INSTEAD APPEAL TO OUR BETTER
ANGELS.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHETHER BLACK, WHITE OR
HISPANIC THAT WANT TO COME
TOGETHER AS ONE AMERICA
PARTICULARLY AT A TIME WHEN WE
HAVE BOTH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AND A MASSIVE ECONOMIC
CRISIS DIVIDING US IN TURNING
PEOPLE AGAINST EACH OTHER IS NOT
GOOD OR BENEFICIAL AS MUCH AS
THE MEDIA LOVES TO DO IT.
>> I THINK THAT’S WHAT YOU SAID
IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT HOW NICE
WOULD IT BE IF WE HAD LEADERS
WHO COULD BRING US TOGETHER.